if you're a fan of the fable series
you were probably bummed out when
Lionhead Studios shuttered last year but
there's a chance we'll see more of those
games in the future I'm Tony and this
GameSpot news update has a sliver of
hope head of Xbox Phil Spencer was asked
on Twitter if we'd ever get a fable for
his response nothing to announce right
now but I do think the IP has a lot of
places it could go it's obviously not a
confirmation but Spencer's statement
does make it sound like fable could be
resurrected and hey III is only a few
weeks away so maybe we'll hear something
there be sure to hit that subscribe
button to be the first to know if
anything gets announced Microsoft's e3
briefing will commence on Sunday June
11th at 2 p.m. Pacific 5 p.m. Eastern
for reference the last core fable game
was fable 3 which released on Xbox 360
in 2010 but for more on an xbox game you
can definitely play this year check out
our newest Lobby discussion on Call of
Duty World War 2
[Music]